game - here we go
alrighty team black again what do you do
hit him what a French the French alright
follow through
swing the bat completely around free
baseball fans okay we're having I just
kibitz the game where we have this the
advanced French Queen b6 if you play the
French advance you better prepare to
have pressure on that Square on d4 I
like to take this approach this Queen b6
Bishop d2 line you notice in that game I
kibitz lot just a few minutes ago one of
the very first things I pointed out was
that this Bishop has seen better days he
was the bad Bishop well I'm trying to
get rid of what's bad and then what will
I be left with right exchange after bad
you're left with just a good guy here
and this is also just good it's good
it's good for a couple of reasons right
one it's just a bad guy of the two and
also I have less space since White has
upon established on e5
I would like I'm welcome to in other
words I'm welcome to exchanging a set of
pieces off so if one reason was not good
enough for you now you have to so the
other thing to question is should I take
the bishop and help light develop the
queen or should I move forward with just
my development
um I don't know
knight c6 Bishop takes Bishop pawn takes
pawn and my candidate moves I want to be
a bit cautious about pawn takes if I
develop my tonight let's say here I'm
instructing my bishops you know I would
like to recapture my bishop maybe maybe
I should just maybe I'm okay with
helping white develop like that and I
think now yeah you know what I'm gonna
do I'm gonna take care because I don't
want to run into I want to maybe make
use of be for one day
and the other thing I want to do is not
run into pawn takes Bishop takes b4
stuff and I start getting kicked around
so now without c3 around there is no
support for b4 advance the current state
in the center is of course that it's now
closed it's locked so playable and so on
the wings the C file in particular and
then the last thing really for me to
solve is what to do with these minor
pieces my knight typically my queen
Knight would typically like to go to c6
but this Knight has to take two steps
before he could really be in a decent
position so the way I'm going to
organize my development is to bring my
King Knight to c6
my queen Knight to d7 or I don't know
maybe maybe there's thoughts of a six at
one point I think I'll reserve this
guy's options
so this Knight is pretty much going to
go here I'll have a second guy hitting
at d4 second piece hitting at d4 and I
wonder if I could devote a moment to
what I wonder if I could devote a moment
to playing h6 before the bishop could
play to g5 I was saying earlier that I'm
welcome to peace exchanges but maybe
only to a certain extent because if the
dark square Bishop scum off well maybe I
don't want them maybe I don't want
exchanged r-square bishops because why
why would I want to not exchanged our
square bishops
I think for as long as this guy remains
around I'm allowed to do what I'm
allowed to maybe enter positions where I
have maybe a good versus bad bishop or a
good night versus a bad bishop so I feel
that this guy is some sense a liability
now I was thinking knight c6 and then h6
but you know what there's something I'm
a bit fearful of it's the night making
use of g5 and then the Queen coming out
to h5 I think if the knight gets to g5
he's not so easily kicked with h6 Knight
g5 h 6 there's queen h5 and the pond is
in a pin in additionally there's a
there's pressure on f7 I could play g6
but then I'm making additional
weaknesses if I have to okay whoa whoa
now that is what you call a move I did
not expect okay this is um this scares
me let that let that be known that's the
that's my first thought it's a move that
simply scares me Queen takes Knight
takes I can't I can't defend both of
these squares so easily so I think what
I'm needing to do is allow my opponent
to just smash up the Queen side
structure but I think I'll still be okay
or I have hopes that if things are going
to be okay
Knight here Knight here I could block
Queen takes Knight takes but again night
playing here I can't I can't defend both
I could block with my queen however
Queen hear Queen takes pawn takes then
my C pawn becomes a liability would I be
able to exchange him off all the
questions where are the answers
where are the answers to all these
questions I'm throwing out there just
gonna go with that if the knight now
follows here I can bump my king up to d7
I'm perfectly fine with what I'm
perfectly fine with being on castled
that's for sure this is exactly where I
would like to be as the endgame
approached which as the endgame
approaches as the position simplifies
this is fine my king typically another
thing that is he would like to be on a
light square of the two two choices he
has with light and dark off the dark
square since my opponent has that push
up I don't have another square for this
night this is the number one guy that I
want to get rid of get rid of this
tonight my plan pretty much here is
going to be what Bishop up because he's
very limited as well
I'm pretty much running with the moves
where I have the least amount of
flexibility let's go
rook on H to ca so that so that now what
so that now if my King needs to run he
could come back here if he's ever forced
and if he's ever in check he could run
back and not be interfering with the
rooks coordination if I went with this
rook that could maybe be a problem down
the line light squares had my weakened
this a six move I didn't touch on it
rules out any pieces getting to be four
but what it does allow is maybe a knight
to sink itself in on b3 these pawns one
could argue our weakness but are they
really weakness if you know my opponent
can't exploit them I think it could turn
out to be quite all right
Knight a5 eyes both of these squares and
I think it's the thing to do however do
I just play here right now the night's
going to have to exchange itself off
let's do that right now
preme of this he's the he pretty much
had to go there there was no retreat
retreat retweet
that's when you know you're on Twitter
too much not retreat retweet
okay do I double rooks or play to a five
okay that's the big plan that's the big
question I should say oh wait a second
no no no no no I'm gonna get rid of one
of my double pawns I'm gonna play here I
have enough support for it and if the
knight place to b3 I'm not afraid
because of just b6 cancels out the night
so this is like a little slinky here
then the head moves and then the tail
moves right after it right do I do I
stop this but it takes a moment oh I
think I do because if this advance is
really to get in then I want the G file
to open up maybe there's some checks
against the king at some point addition
okay well we're just gonna have a time
issue but I think well if I play here
maybe the knight could decide to shift
gears and come over and make use of g5
so I was thinking h5 to stop g4 make
this the idea
not so great anymore but okay I'm just
gonna go at this and now last question
is really oh I should have I should have
considered maybe rook takes first and I
think it's gonna matter is it time's up
and I didn't I wasn't I didn't have too
much time as well
okay ah good game let's let's go back
here and let's flip the board and see
how either one of us could have improved
so French advance what is it that white
could be doing different now one thing I
think to be aware of is when you see
black going with this idea if you're
here the sighted plays French and let's
get more specific if you play the French
advance and you're seeing this idea of
trying to eliminate the light square
bishop anticipate b5 you've pretty much
as black I'm saying I want to get this
in and it's a reason of course to not
run with the very natural looking knight
c6 because it interferes with the Bishop
b5 movies simply can't do that if you're
developing
Queen night before you know you go with
Bishop d7 to b5 what I'm getting at is
that sometimes I've run into a bishop b5
being met with c4 and things become very
tricky very very tricky for example
maybe even in this position after I play
that you could consider c4 it's I think
a temporary pawn sacrifice and there's
some mental calculation that you'd have
to run forward with right now as I go
over these moves but after c4 I'm not
sure which one is best capture let's
just say Bishop takes Bishop takes pawn
Bishop takes Bishop on takes the idea
here for white is to not exchange this
deep on for the C pawn but rather the D
pawn for the e pawn so by pushing the d5
White has to take otherwise I think this
pawn is just too dangerous getting to d6
and such so pawn takes Queen takes after
the smoke clears the Queen is centrally
located on d5 she'd be hitting one of
the doubled pawns that aren't c4 and
looking more long-term when you have the
deep on exchanging itself off for this
epon white then has a 4 versus 3 4
versus 3 majority on the King side so
it's just something to be aware of this
c4 advance with the continuation
eventually being d5 we didn't have that
things were much more quiet and I say
that because the we had a static
structure a closed center and it was
just trying to get pieces to good
squares and I think well if initially
the Queen b5 move scared me but I guess
my response is going to being quite all
right
and the doubled be pawns okay they look
ugly but I don't know if you could
really exploit them so maybe maybe maybe
it isn't best but let's let's let's
would have a look at something else
because this this thing that I was
talking about earlier
stopping the night coming from GFI
coming to g5 maybe maybe you could get
that in no I didn't really give you a
moment to do that like the night isn't
really even threatening to do that right
now because of the pressure on this pond
but that that's just still another idea
to be aware of the night moving out and
the Queen coming here we didn't we
didn't run into that situation but
anyhow BB ponds I think black is fine
right now
not really an issue and again with this
Bishop around I'm still in a position as
black now to enter good versus bad
bishop or a good night versus bad Bishop
I want to keep this guy around and he he
was still around to the very end of the
game but by this time we had the flag
falling the time running out so all
right all right good game good game to
you